تطورات كثيره في الخليل لاسما في مخيم
العروب هل اجمل تها
لنا نعم زين العابدين دعني ابدا باخر
التطورات والمستجدات في هذه اللحظات قوات
الاحتلال تقتحم بلده شيوخ شمال الخليل
وتقوم
بمداهمة في شوارعها جاء ذلك بعد اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال لمنطقه الظهر في بلده بتمر
شمال الخليل هذه الليله وهناك اندلعت
مواجهات بين الشبان وقوات الاحتلال اطلقت
خلالها قوات الاحتلال قنابر الغاز السامه
المسيل للدموع وفتشت عددا من منازل
المواطنين كما دلعت مواجهات وصفت بالعنيف
بين شبان وقوات الاحتلال في مخيم العروب
شمال الخليل خلال هذه المواجهات قوات
الاحتلال اطلقت الرصاص الحي وهذا الرصاص
اصاب مركبه تابعه لمركبه اسعاف تابعه
للجنه الشعبيه في مخيم العروب شمال الخليل
وا اصابها رصاص الاحتلال الحي بشكل مباشر
لهذه المركبه كما اطلق الاحتلال في مخيم
العروب قنابر الغاز السام المسيل للدموع
ايضا في بلده صريف شمال الخليل المستوطنون
اطلقوا الرصاص الحي باتجاه احد الشبان وهو
يبلغ من العمر 24 عاما هذا الا ادى الى
اصابته نقل عبر مركبه اسعاف تابعه للهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني الى احد مشافي الخليل
لتلقي العلاج وهذا ليس الاعتداء الاول
الذي يقوم فيه مستوطنون تحديدا في بلده
صريف شمال الخليل حيث جرت العاده ان يقوم
المستوطنون بالاعتداء على المزارعين
تحديدا الذين يصلون الى اراضيهم لحراستها
وزراعتها في هذه الايام تحديدا في تله
الصمود في يطا جنوب الخليل قوات الاحتلال
اقتحمت هذه المنطقه
وداهمت وفتشت عدد من منازل المواطنين
وعملت على تخويف المواطنين وترويعهم كما
وردتنا الانباء من هناك كما قامت قوات
الاحتلال في وقت سابق من ظهر يوم امس
بمصادره مركبه في منطقه قريه منيزل وهي
تابعه لمسافر يطا جنوب الخليل هذه مجمل
التطورات المتلاحقه حتى اللحظه في الخليل
الابرز والاهم هو الاقتحام المستمر
والمتواصل الان لبلده الشيوخ شمال الخليل
an